welcome to exploring computing
today's video is web page example
history blog so in our last example we
saw the use of class
in a number of places we saw that we
created a class for captions
and a class for photographs and a
separate class for write photographs
versus love photographs
and this idea of taking divs
or other elements we've been giving and
providing them with classes can be quite
powerful
one of the places that this often shows
up is in blogs
so here i've got a blog about stanford
history
and you can see i've done some
formatting on it
and in fact you're going to get a chance
to do some formatting on this
for your next homework assignment so
we will be providing you with the html
for this file
but not the css so we do want you to
create css from scratch
but let's go over the css that i used in
order to get the
current look that we're looking at right
here all right so
if we think about how this blog works
there's a number of different elements
on the blog
so there's a bunch of entries in the
blog and each of the entries has a
heading
with the title and then there's some
dates
and i don't have a footer shown here but
we'll see that in the source there's
actually a footer and then the number of
tags
that you can display for each of the
entries on the blog
and so these are all different elements
that commonly show up in blogs
now if you look at the source of a blog
often you'll see that
what they've done is they've taken a
number of these
items and some of them might be
paragraphs some of them might be divs
some of them might actually be headings
and they will go ahead and give them
classes so this is what my source code
looks like for each of the entries in
the blog
and you can see i've given a class for
the entries class for the heading
which has a title and the date in it a
class for the content
a class for the footers and a class for
the
tags that go on the footers you as i
mentioned
in the end of the caption example there
are some new html5
elements that don't actually provide any
formatting on their own
uh but may be used to provide a bit of
semantic information so the example
that was relevant for that particular
example was there's a figure and a
figure caption
um entry and so you could replace the
class equals entry here with the article
html5 element
but when i went to look at a number of
blogs that are actually on the web i
didn't see any of them using those
techniques now it could be that
these are just older blogs and that's
why they're using the techniques i'm
showing you here or
it could be that modern blogging
software has not been updated to use
those
elements but regardless the blogs that i
looked at look
pretty close to what we're seeing here
so we're going to go ahead and
continue using this okay so what i'm
going to do here is we're going to go
through and we're going to take a look
at some
examples of how i did formatting with
this blog
and so again i think the things to keep
in mind are one
this idea that we have a bunch of divs
and in one case we actually have an h2
if you look carefully
the heading there actually does have an
h2 there we have a bunch of divs and the
h2
and we are classifying them by putting a
class
attribute value pair on them as i said
this shows up all the time
and then two as we go through the
formatting that i did on each of these
um we'll see various different
formatting features that i will point
out to you that may be useful for your
own work
so let's start off with the entry title
um and so you can see this
is uh this is the leland
stanford purchases lan or the university
established or the earthquake dev
states campus these are my h2s
and you can see that i have the h2 but
i've also given the class
entry title and so i'm going to go ahead
and write a rule to apply to the entry
titles
i suppose i could also use it for h2s
assuming there aren't other h2s on the
web page
um you can imagine maybe i have a
sidebar that has an h2
or maybe some advertisements that use h2
but
i've gone ahead and chose to use the
entry title uh
class selector rather than the h2
selector you see i'm given a font size a
font weight
now i think i mentioned earlier that
there are actually font weights can go
between 100 and 900
you could also set font weight to bold
um i've set a color and then i think the
interesting one
for this entry that we haven't talked
about is this font family here
notice i've actually listed three font
families
times new roman times and then serif
if you list a number of different font
families what will happen
is the web browser will look for each of
these font families and as soon as it
finds one that matches it will go ahead
and use that
so there's a font that you're not sure
is going to be on the person's computer
you can go ahead and list several fonts
um
and you know going from the order of the
hey
i really hope they have this font
installed but if they don't
let's try this font and if they don't
have that one let's try this font and
then you can end up with either serif or
sans serif
which are two of the primary choices in
terms of design
and we'll talk about those more in the
design web design lecture
anyway the main point i wanted to
mention here is just this idea that
you can list several fonts for the font
family and it will go with
whichever one it finds first in the list
okay here's how i set up the entry dates
um if you look in the image on the right
i know it's a little bit small there
but you can see the dates are on the far
right and they are alongside the actual
blog entries and how did i did that
i did that by using float so i floated
the
entry dates to the right um i didn't
have to set a width on this i know in
the
caption example i talked about how you
should be careful about
to set widths on text uh when you're
floating it
however in this case since the dates are
actually years and they can never be
more than four characters that wasn't
that wasn't an issue
you are going to want to set a width on
floating elements
if they are text and if they are
potentially long because as you may
recall from our discussion
with the captions on the images if you
have a really long caption
and you don't put a width on it it will
expand out to take as much of the web
page as it can
including the entire web page if it's a
long enough caption
you can limit that by putting a width on
it here i'm not limiting it again just
because i know that they're only four
characters long
okay for each of the entries i have you
can see i have those red lines running
across
above and below each entry uh how did i
do that
well here i put a top border which is
two pixels
solid red and in addition i put a little
bit of extra padding and margin
above each element um you'll notice that
the padding in the margin actually lists
four different values what is up with
that
well here's how that works if you
go ahead and set a single value it is
the padding
or margin for uh
for all four directions if you set
two of them you're setting a top and
bottom and then a left and a right
and if you set all four it starts in the
top goes to the right
goes to the bottom goes to left so in
this case i could have said
padding top and margin top
but i thought it'd be more interesting
to switch things up so you could see
this other technique
now one of the issues that comes up is
this particular rule
is putting a red line
above each of the entries because i have
the border top set to two pixels
but i'm not actually setting a bottom
border so how am i going to get the
bottom border there are several ways to
do this
i think the most common technique is to
add a
class to the last item and you can see
here's the last entry here
i've added this class last on to it
and then i've written a rule that
applies to just
items that have class last
and so i've given the last item a border
bottom of two pixels
solid red and so all the entries have
a top border and the last entry has a
bottom border
and so that's how i get those four lines
the three on top and then the fourth
line below all the elements
but there are other ways of doing this
so um
if you want to get fancy we talked about
this briefly i mentioned this briefly
when we were talking about pseudo
classes that there are these last
pseudo classes so there's a last child
and
a last of type and so here's the last
child and so you can see all my entries
actually fit in this div called
main and so if i write a rule that
applies to the
last child in main that will apply to
that bottom
div i could also write a last of type
rule and so here i'm saying
i want this to apply to an entry uh
but i only wanted to apply to the last
of that
type so the last thing with an entry
class and you can see that
um i can go ahead and use that to to put
a
bottom border on just the last of my
entries
okay so originally i did not have a
footer but when i decided to turn this
into homework assignment for all of you
i wanted to have a little bit more
interesting
stuff for you guys to play around with
so i added a footer but
i wasn't really quite sure what to do
with the footer so i kind of cheated
so i thought i'd show you this little
technique that i used to cheat
and that is you can actually make items
disappear
there's two different techniques to make
it disappear
this one is the display none and so what
this does is this just completely
removes that element
so you can see here i've got an entry
footer here if you look at the
bottom of my html section here you can
see that there's a
div class entry footer and that there's
a bunch of entry tags
for this particular item and i decided i
didn't want any of them to show up by
the way you guys don't get to do this
for your homework
do something interesting with the
footers and the tags
okay so uh by setting display to none
it just completely disappears as if it
did not exist
the other way to make something
invisible is to set visibility to hidden
this actually does something a little
bit different than saying display
none though if you set the visibility to
hidden what happens is
the space where that element would have
been if it had been placed normally will
still be there
the item just will not be shown on that
space so
if we were to do this you'd actually see
some blank spaces
for those entry footer divs
down at the bottom of each of these
entries so you'd see a little bit of
extra space uh
where these circles are i didn't
actually do
visibility hidden so the image you see
on the top right is actually with
display none
just as the other images in this series
have
i've shown that but you can play with
these two settings display none or
visibility hidden
okay um also we did this with the
caption example but i thought i just
mentioned it really briefly i did
surround the entire thing with the div
i gave it the id all and then i used the
auto on the left to the right margin
that's how i went ahead and centered
everything
okay so this idea of taking a bunch of
elements and adding a class to it
that actually turns out to be pretty
powerful
and so the idea here is html does not
necessarily
have tags for everything we think
might be potentially interesting and so
if there isn't a tag available a
specific tag available we can go ahead
and sort of add one of our own
by using a div or one of the other tags
and actually giving it a class
and so there's there's a group that's
really gone and run with this sort of
idea and that's the micro formats
organization
and um so we're going to take a look at
two micro formats the first one we're
going to take a look at has to do with
reviews
so suppose i was looking at uh you know
thinking about going to the movies
sadly can't do that right now um and i
heard this avengers end game movie was
out and i wanted to know
hey is avengers end game any good and so
i could go ahead google it
and by google avengers end game review
you can see that some of the reviews
actually have these
stars in uh google so google somehow
knows that
those are reviews and that they've given
them a
certain number of stars and it's able to
display those stars
uh in the search results how does it
know
that it's a review and that um
the reviewer gave a certain number of
stars well
um google supports a micro format called
h review
and so here's the h review what the h
review format looks like and this is an
example from the microformats.org
website
and if you look at this you'll see that
throughout the
html here there's a whole bunch of
classes i'm just going to focus on two
of them up here at the top
there's a class h review that google can
look at and say oh
this does follow the age review format
and then there's a
class rating and by google looking for
that class rating
and seeing the number there that's
actually how it can determine how many
stars to put
in the summary another micro format that
shows up fairly frequently is the
v card or h card uh format and this is
for
virtual business cards and so the idea
here is
um you know people often have business
cards that they can to people so people
can
get information like their contact
information
and so the idea behind the h card or v
card
is that you can put that sort of
information on your website
but um it's not enough to just put the
information on your website if you want
people to be able to pull that
information off and store it in a
separate program
however if you were to put that
information on your website
notify people that you are using this
specific technique
in this case the vcard technique
tools that are designed to work with
vcards can
search through the html tags looking for
specific entries with specific classes
so you can see here i can see that
there's a class
street address there's certainly no html
tag for street address but
by putting class equals street address
on it i'm letting any tool that's
designed to work with these
vcards no that's my street address it
can go ahead and pull the information
out of that tag
169 university avenue can go ahead and
stuff it into
the the virtual business card database
similarly there's a postal code there's
a telephone number
there's an email address
these are all things that don't have
html
tags associated with them there we will
discover later there is an email
for a form entry where people can type
in email
but in general things like the postal
code the country name
cell phone number and presenting the
email as opposed to entering the email
into a form
these do not have html
tags but by putting classes on them
i am able to provide classification
information that a program designed to
read web pages can go ahead and pick
that information out
and go ahead and process it so again i
just wanted to emphasize this idea that
putting classes on elements can can be
used for quite a number of different
purposes
all right that's it for this example